here now with reaction is south carolina
senator lindsey graham senator good to
see you by the way the world is ending
in 12
years yeah that's what i hear uh
a lot of issues here um how could
anybody
look in the eye of a parent that lost a
kid
from a heroin overdose and not say or
say that this is manufactured or
look in the face of an angel mom or dad
same issue there
and not even be willing to talk about
the issue with the president
when it's life and death safety and
security
and yeah then it put out all of these
demands
it makes it impossible well what you
don't have is uh clips of democratic
senators saying this because they know
it's a death blow to the party
president trump made a brilliant
political move and good for the country
to go to the middle wall plus daca plus
tps
i've had more democratic senators talk
to me in the last two days
then talked to me in the last 30 days
the harder
nancy pelosi goes left and the more
trump goes to the middle
we're going to get this thing solved
well tomorrow i can see chuck schumer
lining up all the democrats to vote
against that compromise plan
and again tpa daca dreamers
and by the way the house on the fro
wanting to pay the furloughed employees
the republicans no democrats supporting
that either so i guess that was a lie
also
well what's going to happen you'll have
a vote tomorrow on president's plan that
will get almost all republicans very few
democrats
we'll have schumer's proposal that i'll
vote against then the hard work starts
we had a meeting today with about eight
democrats and about eight republicans
and
you know nancy pelosi has become a
nightmare for the democratic party
she seems unreasonable she seems to have
a dislike for the president
that is hurting the country and this
idea of not letting the president speak
is really overplaying your hands so i
want to let your listeners know
that there's a reaction to this far left
rhetoric
in the senate by more mainstream
democrats that i think will eventually
allow us to get the wall funded and do
some things for the daca recipients
and tps recipients there's a deal in the
making and the more extreme nancy pelosi
gets
the more likely we'll have a deal it can
include amnesty you're going to lose
every conservative
supporter of the president but it's not
included the president was pretty clear
about that i promise you it will not
okay um it seems like nancy pelosi is
intimidated
and afraid of this new radical extreme
element i think so
i think she fears that she will lose her
position as speaker very quickly
um what is your take in interpretation
on the constitution article two section
three
well i think the president has a lot of
power i mean she can disinvite him to
the house but come to the senate mr
president
there's plenty of places the president
can choose to deliver the state of the
union
but here's the question for america what
kind of union do you want
do you want a country that looks more
like venezuela and less like america
if you do follow these hard left people
they're going to take you to the land
where the government taxes everything uh
in its power
they control every decision in life and
you'll see venezuela come here
this is what this whole election is
going to be about in 2020.
do we go further left and become like
like venezuela but
we've come to america that all of us
want us to be so if i'm a democrat
these people are defining my party in a
way that gives it a very
limited future in america in my view so
the president
to me obviously and i agree with him use
this as life and death
safety and security the american people
stopping the heroin
90 percent of the heroin in this country
from coming across the border
fentanyl um he's about life and
that seems like a principled strong
position
also part of his when he when he pledges
to
faithfully serve and protect the
constitution that means his people he's
the commander-in-chief
as for the constitution what is the
democratic position
they don't want daca they don't seem to
care about furloughed employees
they don't seem to care about dreamers
right
what is this fight about then for them
they want trump to fail more than they
want the country to win
a dollar for the wall does that make
sense in light of the caravans that have
been coming
a broken border is more dangerous to the
country
than a partial government shutdown in
their world there is no ice
you get a dollar for the wall and the
border patrol agents are gassing
children
not defending the country from an
onslaught
so my view is that democrats in the
senate
are going to become more reasonable as
these people define
extreme positions the president made a
very smart move by putting on the table
relief for daca recipients
tps recipients which the democrats have
been for for decades
now let's see what kind of democratic
party we've got do we have a democratic
party
that hates trump so much they will say
no to 1.1 million people having a better
life
or will we have some democratic senators
and some democratic house members
join with the president and me to solve
this problem
time will tell look the president it
seems
he does have other options when we're
dealing with drugs yes he does
gangs cartels uh human trafficking drug
trafficking
uh real radical elements and that's the
only the two percent i believe the other
98
right that don't respect our laws but
they've come here for a better life for
themselves and their families i believe
that haven't been down there a lot
so then the question is when the
president goes alone
national emergency what happens next
well if i were him i would use my power
as commander-in-chief to build that wall
because he promised to build it
every democrat has voted for wall
funding except when president trump
became president
but here's the way to go i think if i
were the president i would ask nancy
pelosi
if a bill passes the senate that has
wall funding
protection for doc and tbs tps would you
take it up in the house
if she says yes i would open the
government for three weeks
let the senate see if we can reach a
deal and if we can't i would use the
emergency powers as the
commander-in-chief
to bring this debacle to an end um i'm
not sure if he gives up his leverage but
if he's prepared to do
the national emergency he's that means
he's committed
one way or the other getting this done
one way or the other senator good to see
you thanks for being with us